Hành động đang hoàn thiện và chuẩn bị ban hành bằng giá đất mới, ác dụng từ ngày 1,5 năm 2021.
Theo lần đất đai năm 2021 và nghị định số 1,5 năm 2021.
Bằng giá lần này được chia thành mối bệ khu vực, thêm vi theo dân dưới hành chính như trước,
thế hiện định hưởng được kết hợp lý sữa các khu.
Giá đất tại khu vực trung tâm tăng nhẹ khoảng 2分 chăm, trong khi ngoại thành tăng bình quân 2,5分 chăm,
cao nhất tại đàn phục hoại được.
Bực phân hoại này phần ánh số lượng dịch chuyển phát triển giá ngoại lỗi đô thị,
đông thưi vào đam công 2, bình bệnh ổn định thị trường.
Bằng giá đất mới được khi vọng tạo công cuộc của liệu quả,
2 hoại lợi ít nhẹ nước, xanh nghiệp, người dân có phần phát triển tụi đô bị bứng trong dài đạn mới.